dad i know you're a hugger and i know
you old guys like to sniff hair you
can't do that however you feel about it
if someone asks you to put on the mask
in public just put on the mask because
if you don't put on the mask someone's
going to videotape you i don't want you
to get cancelled nobody will talk to you
ever again you can't ask someone to hug
so you can't say should we hug you might
as well just ask somebody right now are
we
what
you're gonna need to diversify your
friends so right now it's pretty wide
around the house if you don't want to
get canceled you need to have one of
every friend what do you get so far when
you hug you can't touch each other so
it's like an air hug
but you can't get your arms all the way
because now we've trapped them in the
circle of discontent this is actually a
form of assault now so if you lock
finger somebody this is like kidnapping
in the second degree and they'll throw
you in jail you got an asian friend he
doesn't really like you but that's okay
will they come and stand by you for the
picture you get one black friend greg
the same black friend you've been
claiming to have for 30 years now when
we hug also you can't make any of those
noises you used to make
there's no rubbing the back there's no
padding in the back and it's not called
a hug anymore it's called a
the good was offending people that's the
good sound i know you're still working
at the hardware store say somebody walks
in and buy something and you say thank
you come again it's 2021 you can't tell
people when to come
or go you just have to say thank you now
you're not even supposed to say thank
you for buying something because then
that's like a trick into getting someone
to buy again which is a micro aggression
instead of thank you you would say okay
because you don't want to say have a
good day because maybe they don't want
to have a good day maybe they want to
have a bad day and who are you to tell
them
what kind of day to have
are you the boss of them it has to just
be like okay and then just
this not this right
this and make sure you just give a
little one of these but you can't do
this cause that's like the queen that's
cultural appropriation your person who
mows your lawn how do you refer to him
as mario you can't do that anymore i
can't refer to him by his name because
it sounds racist
i know it's his name it doesn't matter
so you have to say
excuse me your venerable
lawn attendant sir if they want you to
stand six feet apart six foot park if
they want you to hum a song you gotta
hum a song because the whole thing is
not offending people if they want you to
call it cheese and macaroni instead of
macaroni and cheese that's what you
gotta do we are here to make other
people comfortable that's what the new
generation is how can i make you
comfortable
doesn't matter how i feel what is best
for you even if i don't understand it
when you want to get a
you need to get consent you have to get
a consent form
for the consent form i can't make you
fill out a consent form so i need to get
your consent
to slide you a consent form because i
don't want to offend you with a consent
form so i need to ask your permission
to ask your permission
to get a
i don't have proof
that i was a consensual baby
which is a microaggression against me
which causes me
anger
which indirectly affects my kids
so then my kids need to go to therapy
now those therapists
need to get paid now if we don't pay
those therapists it affects their family
my kids therapist kids
could sue you
for damages
so i'm going to need a consent form just
so i know that i was a consensual child
and that mom wanted to have sex with you
and then have me it's gonna be two
content forms one is a consent to the
sex the other one is consent to have the
baby so i'm gonna need you to get a
consent form from mom now
tricky that she's dead
so